[Music]
hello my name is comfor I'm a computer
vision researcher in the intelligent
input group today I'm going to introduce
three pieces work here which we enable
any users to render artistic Estelle we
show artifacts in good looking for both
images and videos so the first piece of
work we are going to present is called a
style bank which is presenting what
happened which is summarized in a paper
we published in civil PR this year in
this piece of work we propose a XP see
the representation of wishes house as a
set of collusion conditional filters in
the compose the immediate space because
of this explicitly representation we can
do faster rendering and the faster
incremental landing of different styles
here I show you some results here
as you can see we can render the styles
in a pretty consistent way for a large
world of different visual styles so
several advantages here is that lega it
enables faster training of new styles
for example if we want to inquiry can
fix the most of the parameters fixed and
we only need to use like eight minutes
to train a new model versus the existing
work early it's like several hours the
second C is that we can quickly render
loose tiles by holding the intermediary
the representation fixed and we just
need to swap the different filters and
also we can easily do linear fusion of
different styles by linear combination
of the filters what is even more
importantly we can do region specific
estelle fusion for example we can render
different regions of the image with
different the visual styles as you can
see this is our future results with
different styles so next where I'm going
to show we can apply the techniques to
videos like a but as you can imagine
makeup when you render the results frame
to frame it is going to have a lot of
shimmering so in this work we propose a
algorithm which can leverage the
consistence across frames like a we can
generate much more stable with your
results you can see the difference
so in the set of piece of work we are
going to show the black trick where we
can swap the style of two images
traditionally image generality work like
you have a three input and one output
here we try to generate two outputs from
a pair of inputs so in our methods we
take a very complicated approach where
we run the images through deep networks
and we do patch matching and it's
warping the correspondence and do some
multi-resolution reconstruction as a
results we dynamically show you that we
can actually deform and just render the
two images in different styles here I'm
going to present a little bit more
results here as you can see we can sort
of render the source image in two
different outputs based on the reference
here are some poor results we compare
with the existing offering like our
results are always more consistent than
the visually more pleasant especially
for portrait photos
and here we can even render the input
source file to like a sketch face to a
real face and here are some more
examples
and you can also do facial makeup
transfer if you ever face look good you
can try to mimic the same kind of facial
makeup and here are more on faces like
we're under the same face in two
different styles like the Mona Lisa
looking and a bunch of other artistic
styles so actually the first piece of
technology indeed has been transferred
into makers of the picks which is the AI
camera of produced from our group and
the rest of the technology are under
transferring into different Microsoft
product perhaps you will see it in some
of those offerings thank you